ما يحدث في غزة اليوم ليس
حربًا، بل هو محاولة إبادة جماعية من قبل إسرائيل
للتوصل إلى حل نهائي
لمشكلتهم، وهذا الحل النهائي ينطوي على
قتل جميع الناس في غزة
وخاصة حماس ولكن أيضًا أشخاص آخرين
في غزة يريد الإسرائيليون قتلهم كما يريدون.
أكبر عدد ممكن من الناس
وحتى الآن قتلوا حوالي
8000 شخص والأمم المتحدة
مشلولة لذلك الأمم المتحدة غير قادرة
على اتخاذ أي قرار على الإطلاق. لا
تستطيع الدول الإسلامية سوى التعبير عن التعاطف
والدعم ولا شيء غير ذلك لأنها
ليست في وضع يسمح لها بذلك.  اتخاذ إجراءات
لمنع إسرائيل من الهجمات ضد
غزة يحاول أماس الدفاع عن
أراضيه التي استولت عليها
إسرائيل، وهو إجراء دفاعي
لاستعادة الأراضي المفقودة، فهو لا
يهاجم إسرائيل فقط من أجل لا شيء، فقد استولت إسرائيل على
أرض حماس والأراضي الفلسطينية، لذا فإن
أه من حق الفلسطينيين أن يحاولوا
استعادة أرضهم أمريكا والدول
الأوروبية خلقت إسرائيل
استولوا على أرض فلسطين وجعلوها
دولة إسرائيل لذلك الآن
يدافعون عما خلقوه القادة العرب
ويجب على كل الدول الإسلامية أن تكون في
صف  أيها الشعب الفلسطيني في غزة،
حسنًا، سيكلف الأمر الكثير من
الناس وسيقتلون، ولكن إذا كنت
تريد الدفاع عن أراضيك، فعليك أن تخاطر
بالقتال ضد
القوة الساحقة
لإسرائيل